what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host on sockin we are now
following up for our second round with
dr. Stanley krypter dr. Jurgen Cramer
hello you two hi Alan good to be talking
to you again thanks for coming back on
the program yes once again to the breach
hey I'm really happy that we'll have the
opportunity to talk to you both at the
same time and we wanted to start things
off by talking about the importance of
balance who wants to kick us off start
elders first balance is a word that you
run into time and time again in terms of
indigenous native cultures because they
strive for balance between human beings
and the rest of nature but they also
strive to art internal balance and yes
there are very very wise they have
vacations from balance they do very
exciting things in terms of their games
they have very orgastic experiences they
take chances they take risks so it's fun
to depart from balance once the well if
you can come back and re-establish the
balance again valence often makes people
think that that things are bored don't
both far from it the better things are
balanced the better equipped you are to
avoid boredom by taking a little
adventures now and then maybe two
footnotes to that one is that balance
really should be a verb because it's
always balancing we are never in balance
you know if a tightrope walker things
okay I have balance and stops they're
going to fall off right so balance is
always a process
and that's just one of the most
important things about it and really the
contrast that I think we're making is
between striving for balance working
with balance you know playing for
balance versus progress and having well
you know that line up but really in
evolution that happens by as constantly
balancing ourselves with each other
inside of ourselves with the world
around us and changing because we're
doing that kind of work and I think
that's for me that's very very important
no I agree with that balance does not go
up or go down that's not the way that
goes but it doesn't stand still either
dynamic balance is what keeps your life
interesting
absolutely yeah and play is just as
important as deep thought mm-hmm I've
really loved the analogy that you're
painting where you're walking on the
tightrope and when you think I have
balance is when you fall off so it's
this constant balance being a verb
balance sink always in balance this idea
of a constant ebb and flow and that
there's never a period of stopping it's
always in a band flow
always in the progress this part I'm
continued to have some interest in this
part especially the idea of having deep
interconnectedness with all yet also
having a directional arrow towards
progress that is the balance that's kind
of a modernity balance that we're aiming
to strike maybe yes keep your teeth
teach maybe you see I increasingly look
at progress as an ideology and I think
when we when we balance ourselves we are
really working towards integration we're
working to greater health to greater
imagination
and you can call that evolution you can
give that directionality but really you
know when you look at different cultures
they carry different imaginations and at
their root they have different ways of
balancing themselves and different
understanding of a balance and that's
really the diversity of the human
experience and I think that's very very
important and I don't want to presuppose
that we're going in one particular
direction or the other
but when we're actually being true to
the work of balancing something new will
emerge something creative will emerge
because we are in that process of you
know right-brain left-brain
communicating with each other you know
the integration with our emotional brain
etc so I sort of prefer that language
because it seems like we're so invested
in this notion of progress and progress
usually is understood quantitatively
right by GDP or so yes right you know
those kinds of measures and I think you
know there may be important but I think
ultimately they're they're misguided you
know and they lead us down the wrong
path why is it better that more people
are at Disney World or Disneyland right
I mean there's only one reason greater
profits right but but really there
should be more play there should be more
imagination and that's really what it's
about which is of course what Disney
yeah taps into example regarding the
human heart
obviously the heart has to be balanced
in order to function but if you look
closely at heart beats you find that the
healthy heart is not uniformly balanced
the healthy heart has little jigs and
Jegs every now and then this heart rate
variability
yes the only time when the heart is
balanced is just before death
so a completely uniform heartbeat bad
news bad news in some ways it's
reminiscent of the Greek gods Apollo who
is the god of balance and Dionysus who
is the god of chaos and you don't want
too much chaos but a little bit of chaos
in the heartbeat and in life can be a
good thing mm-hmm in which you know this
is why native cultures indigenous
cultures usually have clowns trickster
people who stir things up so that's
something you can emerge and they don't
care about what it is but they want to
get keep the movement going yes you know
it's part of the aliveness it's part of
the vitality and you know we need more
tricksters you know the trickster in the
Middle Ages was you know the Jester the
court jester was the only person who
could speak truth to whatever the King
you know and I think it's a very
important role and when the sovereign
can't enjoy the joke or the tease or
can't deal with it then there's real
trouble yeah absolutely right about
native people and how they build in this
little bit of chaos with tricksters and
all but also they do with in their
calendar they have a regular calendar
but there are occasional festivals with
a very chaotic in the plane engines
before the European invasions there was
often one day in the year where people
would act out their dreams if somebody
wanted to wear a beautiful garment the
neighbor had fines they got to wear that
garment for one day so the world turned
say down in one day in some tribes if
you wanted to run off to somebody's wife
for a rendezvous you could do it but
just on that's one day I don't think
they allowed women to do the same thing
but I'm not sure I think that the
another aspect of balance to go to not
American unions but Asian Indians when I
was in an Indian factory where they were
making these beautiful rugs they pointed
out that only God is perfect and so the
weaver had to put one imperfection in
the rug so that the rug would not rival
God and sure enough there it was you
could barely see it but finding the
imperfection of the rug what made it
available for human use something
perfect is only for the gods this for me
you know I love this conversation you
know for me really means that we change
our perspective and our thinking and our
habits of thinking because when you look
at something that's happening in terms
of okay you know we need to balance
versus okay we need to progress it gives
you very different solutions yeah and a
very different care about the issue and
I think that kind of you know what we
used to call paradigm shift you know in
in is really important that kind of you
know I mean that's I think genuine and
transformation and it's really hard
because we're habitually so into this
thinking and our language gears us
towards that thinking but is this like
the balance between balance and
evolution possibly yeah you see I think
when your work is balancing then you're
actually not concerned about evolution
yes then you're concerned
the beauty that you create the love that
you generate the compassion that's there
the healing that happens all of that and
you know when there's this wonderful
ceremony that the Karuk Indians in
northern Northern California are doing
which is called a world renewal ceremony
right and it's the world renewal happens
in in their territory in their land
right but also it's for the rest of of
the world right and it's that balancing
act and it's their responsibility like
when the Hopi is do certain ceremonies
there are for themselves but they're
going out and that's their understanding
there for the world right they're not
just for themselves so that that's you
know different from evolution vows you
have to realize that evolution takes a
long long long time yes and so the
balance of the monk person's life is
like a grain of sand I think the balance
on the whole the balancing act or
whatever helps evolution consolidate and
get ready for the next jump so I don't
see you think contradictory be human
balancing and evolution maybe from from
the way that I see it right now is that
this economic machinery is roaring at
such unprecedented levels of sacrificing
the ecology for profit that and there's
never been a pause button this is
another thing to keep in mind there's
never a pause button on the machinery
there's no such thing as globally taking
a 7-day break from work collectively
deciding on when that is happening every
year at a specific time or whatever so
that we can focus on balance which has
nothing to do with economic production
well it does after you kind of finish it
because then people are economically
producing in a more harmonious way with
each other and with nature but it has to
do with healing with with with with all
these other variables that you brought
up about that process of balancing so
that's I guess that's how I view it and
how I hope to help awaken other people
to seeing it as albeit they are right
there going with each other balance and
evolution but there is just something so
deeply natural about balance and nature
and an interconnectedness and there's
something so deeply feels artificial and
out of balance about metropolis and the
economic machinery and sacrificing
ecology well yes you can take examples
like that the one that comes to my mind
in evolution is some of the huge mammoth
that drew horns so large the horns
became unwieldy and started to pierce
the heads of the mammoth and so the
longer the horns drew this more harmful
they were with the mammoth that's not a
number of other things just did the
mammoth sin yeah so I think that the
mammoth we're a great evolutionary
success for a while but eventually they
took the wrong turn it's like the canary
in the coal mine is like the male yes so
again I don't like to glorify or rely
redefine any of these terms of working
with and sometimes evolution does make a
wrong term or come to a blind alley and
just in the nature of things nothing
works out perfectly nothing else in
nature is like clockwork
so there's something that it's very
important that you just said in terms of
you don't want to essential eyes or AFI
these terms and I think if you know that
that is a change in how we use language
right we're using labels lightly and
that is so important and in so many
discussions that doesn't happen well
really there's a little signposts to
understand you know very complex issues
and if we actually learn to use various
concepts of evolution or balance or
whichever term it is lightly and you
know see it as something that we try to
define that we try to understand but
that also has a fuzziness and that is in
and of itself in a process I think that
already would be and I'm going to say it
now
progress oh good point talking about
words again I think we try as we can to
reify progress and just because
something is going apparently upward
doesn't mean it's getting better
we cannot confuse progress with better
and change sometimes something changes
for the worse and as I said before
evolution play the bad trick on the
woolly mammoth which eventually does
itself in answers look at even today
some of the elves have antlers that are
so huge that they get caught in trees
and they die of starvation Wow yes
answers were wonderful to use for battle
but every once in a while the progress
went too far
there is nothing to restrain fold it
back and refine it I think that might be
happening in the civilization dilemma
that you're talking about that we want
to move ahead but what are we moving
ahead for what's the goal of moving
ahead yes in the progress and you know
what you described really is is a
linearity
that you know is is out of balance
because it doesn't take into account the
other parts of ourselves right our
intuitive parts our emotional parts our
imaginative parts and so that's where I
think altered states or integrative
states of consciousness are really
important because they help us to not be
stuck in that linearity but use other
parts of our capacities to imagine to
understand what might not be taken care
of and and that is so important because
everything in education these days the
way the educational system is changing
is based on the paradigm of linearity
monic mono causality and rationality
where the arts and you know certain
types of whatever movement etc etc that
is always the first thing that gets cut
while in fact for balance all these
things are just incredibly important
stem is important yes and there's
approximately I believe this is around
how long ago was around the time of the
Buddha's enlightenment about 2500 years
ago apparently there were somewhere
around 1800 different schools for yoga
and yoga meaning Union in Sanskrit with
the divine that I don't see anywhere on
the planet today so we're looking at a
like you're you're giving these examples
of Arts and Humanities being cut there's
a big out of balance happen there
meanwhile science and stem even we're
still trying to punch the a in there to
make it steam that there is something
really feels
of balance about the way that we can
make a nuclear bomb but we're not
spiritually enlightened enough to talk
about why the [ __ ] are we making a
nuclear bomb and same thing with genetic
engineering yes we want to get delete
this single point mutations that cause
people suffering but then figuring out
how to augment our intelligence who's
getting access to the quantum computers
right away to the general intelligences
what happens with inequality yeah yeah
and this is very important you know
balancing is not anti-technology yes
it's and you know it's about how we use
the technology is not whether we use
technology or not because there is a
balance juice and an imbalance juice and
at times you know we don't know up front
is it gonna be balancing you know at
time sweetie get into a cul-de-sac and
get stuck you know it's a dead end yeah
you know but so that that's very
important that you know there there are
potentials there if we find a balancing
way of using them that's fantastic yeah
um you started wandering us into on
altered states in integrative states of
consciousness and you guys have both
been studying this specific thing as
well as how I kind of led us a little
bit into this but just how if you look
2500 years ago and you see 1800s schools
around Yoga union with the divine where
are these schools now what do these
different subcultures of of indigeneity
around the planet what do they know
about yoga about union with the divine
with the nature with each other that
give them altered states and that that
kind of can balance out the
hyper-rational stem focused modernity
well of course now you have
communication with communication these
different schools of yoga got to know
each other and just by getting to know
each other they merged they join
they were reduced to numbered as long as
you didn't have a good communication in
each goal of yoga what is in a so little
valley or mountain you could have
hundreds of schools of of yoga but once
communications started to come into the
picture
I don't think people meditated less I
think they meditated in fewer ways this
is what communication does and sometimes
the communication does surprising things
there are something like eight hundred
branches of Christianity right now and
you'd hope that they would start to
merge very few of them have and now the
Methodists are strengthening their thing
to split because the main body has come
out in favor of same gender marriage but
the very vocal minority says no way
we're going to leave the main body well
there we have two branches two religions
we used to have a lung and so
communication can also work against unit
heat because if either side didn't know
what the other side was talking about
they could be just doing their own way
going their own way and never knowing
what the alternative was so like
everything communication is a two-way
street
I think resolving these issues they're
you know very profound and pertain to
people's understanding or a sense of
identity really it takes a lot of
patience and part of what we're seeing I
think today is that are resolving these
issues at a large scale is actually
difficult yeah and the speed of
communication is one of the intervening
things because when we actually if we
actually were to sit down here and give
ourselves the space and the time to sit
down for three four five days
and really explore what it is about
either our approval off or resistance to
a particular decision or belief we would
probably we might still disagree but we
might come to an appreciation and
understanding of each other that's very
difficult difficult to do in social
media that's very difficult to do in the
way communication has changed you know
which allows a lot of globalization a
lot of fast communication but these
parts that actually because you know
when ten people sit together and they
disagree with each other that is also a
balancing project a process right how
can we talk to each other right how can
we listen to each other
can I have empathy and compassion with
somebody who says something that I find
obnoxious right how do I do that you
know and and I think that that's a
capacity that we're less and less
exercising well look at the boundaries
of the countries of the world after the
second world war was over we thought now
these boundaries are here for a while
we'll have stability didn't work that
way now there are more countries in the
world than there were at the end of the
Second World War
proliferation of new countries in Africa
couple of new countries in Europe and
even though a few countries are emerging
or a country is taking over from another
country those are counted out when you
have the north and south yemen the north
and south korea the india breaking into
pakistan and bangladesh and even maybe
kashmir one of these days so it's
interesting to me how things flow and
change and just when you have staff you
draw
reach some stability things go up in the
air again and you have something do to
cope with we're talking about balance
and I'm trying to show that yes it's by
and large a good thing in a social
situation but you cannot take it for
granted and because you know I think a
lot of the situations that you were
describing
really it wasn't genuine balance because
there were hidden issues that were not
part of it it wasn't balanced in the
first place right yes yes and so you
know it was a fake balance I mean it was
really more a stalemate rather than a
balance and then eventually that broke
open because the parts that had not be
attended to yes
you know whether it was in East Germany
you know freedom of speech and freedom
of religion etc etc we're modern-day
West Bank and Gaza Strip yes yes you
know then it breaks breaks loose because
you can't and I mean this is I think
something where I wish politicians would
be more more psychological because I
think these kinds of balances or
solutions you can't enforce and you need
to create the space I mean that's me
speaking as a psychologist for these
solutions to emerge out of integrative
states of consciousness that's how I
would say it yeah right out of yeah
rational thought rational critical
analysis imagination connection with you
know with the heart with emotions and if
you don't do all of that the solution
really is ultimately doomed you know or
temper is temporary it's as though then
the the collective trauma that exists
today
has a there's a skillful and a tactful
way to approach the healing that does
not cause further symptoms down the line
where it's kind of this like fake
balance it's fine buried in the
subconscious is fine and
when then two people of maybe a
deferring religion live so closely
together if there is more open hardness
coexisting love interdependence and
interconnection then and that's truly
given the time of five days or a week of
just focusing on that between people or
more again the pausing of the economic
machinery to do exactly that then it
makes it so that the healing process is
just the efficacy of it is so much
greater towards maximizing prosperity
and harmony that's what you know Carl
Rogers you know who we both knew is was
really a master in getting people
together who were highly conflicted and
persisting in a conversation that even
after two days well I wasn't a
resolution necessarily but there was a
movement right there was a model of what
could be done if we were to persist
now you just in the what you just
previously you started out back talking
about collective trauma and I'm not
exactly sure what do you have in mind
there but I think it's a very important
term because it goes back to what Stan
said in the previous conversation
because I would call the collective
trauma when people settled and started
to split off they think that's on the on
the planetary level that's the
collective trauma that all those people
are still grappling with
who have started to split off you know I
call it a normative dissociation right
where we are not in touch with you know
nature with where we don't know what
lives around us etc etc and I think that
that's a very profound and largely
unexplored area non the planet but you
know is this fair to say that it's
something like during the most
primordial days of of evolution couple
million years ago that there's a very
collective tribal energy and then during
these last couple tens of thousands of
years has become more split that we move
into the Fertile Crescent we move into
Europe we move across the Bering Strait
into North and South America this is and
then then we further even tribal eyes
again maybe somebody sees this plant in
a specific way but then the other person
does not see that maybe one of them
begins talking to another animal more
intimately and the other one doesn't see
that so this is where these may be
differences start yeah but let's not
talk about the Bering Strait oh is that
not no we don't agree really not is that
a problem yeah okay there I mean that's
the least thing I think we need to say
okay that there are a lot of problems
with it fair enough there's so much
nuance there yeah we don't even know
about these old civilizations before us
and you know and it's a it's a story
with problematic evidence and there are
other stories that talk about that but
what I wanted to say is that the
indigenous
imagination is is is not collective in
the sense of all over
it's always specific right the some
people in the in the desert of South
Africa they survived there and they can
survive there comfortably because they
understand where they are and they know
how to get into integrative states of
consciousness to do healing yes all of
that yes and so you know which would be
the wrong imagination if you transplant
that to the Arctic right because it's a
different it requires a different way of
balancing a different imagination right
but once we get out of that process of
the imagination you know you know we
talked earlier about you know not
idealizing or Manta sizing indigenous
peoples you know because things have
gone wrong there too but there's
something about the quality of the
paradigm that is so important that we
can learn from yeah right because we
can't go back but we can learn from okay
here maybe missing parts that we have
not attended to and that we should
attend to and I think you know whether
it's humanistic psychology the revival
of shamanism in western territories or
transpersonal psychology any of these
are attempts to get to these places
because there is a hunger for it because
there's this wound you get just light
pollution in metropolis children have
never seen the Milky Way galaxy before
versus thousands of years ago our
ability to perform these incredible
navigational feats across seas or across
land or with our agriculture that
required our understanding of the cosmos
and of the way that different plants
instead of are planted as a monocultures
of of plants are planted as with other
plants that then create a more symbiotic
growth paradigm from that matil comes
back to this point of that
the economic machinery cannot be paused
we can't create the space for a week or
two or four week straight of these great
experiments that you're talking about
where two people of in the US it can be
your classic liberal conservative in
your in your Gaza Strip it can be your
classic is Israeli and Palestinian in
your in your North and South Korea and
your north-south Ireland there there's
so basically any of these points of
conflict or even in the US with we were
talking about this before we started how
even before started the first show how
in Canada we just came back from this
partnership interviews their their
relationship with their First Nations
albeit still colonization has a process
of healing and integration that is at
least um started it started to the
degree of where they start their events
and say we are on the unseeded
territories of the Musqueam Squamish etc
in the US there's still such a lack of
even acknowledging these unseeded
territories of a Native Americans plus
acknowledging the systemic problems that
have occurred from the transatlantic
slave trade etc so we knew we we need
that space you said we need space for
healing yeah yeah but that's what Chris
Ryan talked with you in his conversation
you know because the people the
hunter-gatherers and the people of the
horticulturalists they work much less to
make a living right and well what do
they do they play they do ritual and
ceremony and they attend they have the
space to attend to to community yeah
right and we always have these really I
want to call them fantasies at this
point oh if we progress and if we use
the computers and all of that then
people will have to work less right and
what has happened certainly in this
country all right people are working
working more than ever and there is more
stress than ever
you know it's not like suddenly you see
these people you know saying okay I'll
see you at the dance tomorrow right
median email in comes flat lines while
GDP skyrockets 50% of all new wealth
going to the 1% yes yes I think that all
of this can be applied to the human
psyche as well because if things are so
well balanced why is it that a lot of
healthy people have sub personalities
and these sub personalities might come
out during psychotherapy they might come
out during imagination but many people
don't want to get rid of them they like
them they say oh I'd like to perform as
Chloe today and at the end of the day
Chloe goes to sleep and doesn't wake up
again until imagination calls Chloe out
but I think that there is a need for
innovation that coexists with the need
for balance we were talking about the
trans-pacific voyages these are
incredible voyages in their craft they
came to South Pacific Islands then the
North Pacific Islands from like Hawaii
but then in the meantime there was a
expedition coming on boats from Japan
that according to the archaeological
news of August of this year
goddess far is Idaho and now the oldest
remnant of a habitable village is not of
Alaska not in California but in Idaho of
all places so there is a part of human
nature that likes innovation that likes
to travel that likes to see new things
and this seems inconsistent with balance
but to my way of thinking it's the main
way of maintaining the balance yeah the
healthy balance it's a younger brother
older brother as Kogi and many other
indigenous subcultures talk about this
younger brother going out to explore and
innovate and tinker and this older
brother that understands this is a deep
interconnectedness with all things and
unity and so harmonizing those two yeah
I think the only problem is that the
innovation and that has sort of taken
off on its own without the support
integration you know because we are
curious animals you know when we love to
imagine and we love to test ourselves
right like test by okay if I go across
this big ocean where do I get yeah
challenges you know we like that that
excitement and you know obviously
there's nothing wrong with that it is
well so what do we do with that how do
we do it yes right and where do we put
that and and I think you know the
technologies that you know we've
mentioned earlier they are you know
incredible opportunities the the
question for me is really can we
integrate them right or you know you
keep bringing us back to the economics
of things right is that gonna be the
major driver or is there you know will
we be able to connect it with who we are
as human beings and what makes us humans
and I think it's a it's a real challenge
because you know it's an addictive
paradigm you know it's really an
addictive paradigm and for me it feeds
something it's sort of pseudo feeds
something that's not satisfied
it's a substitute it's a drug yeah in a
way but it doesn't have to be yeah it
doesn't have to be yeah right it can be
that childlike play like exploration
creativity and want to get across that
ocean or we want to get to the next
celestial body because we're curious and
because we want to do it in a way that
is harmonic and at peace with each other
and with nature
versus that is focused solely on the
resource extractive capabilities of us
getting to that celestial body who gets
there first so they can capitalize on
that exact thing so there's these
different ways of viewing and also this
whole notion of conspicuous consumption
is gone rampantly out of control because
it's just over and over again it's like
tenth houses purchased tenth cars
purchased tenth Rolexes purchased
private jets private boats purchased
whispers and it's what are these things
filling within people that have so much
that also don't realize that as they buy
up these things like real estate that
what happens to the artists and the
entrepreneurs and the other spiritual
leaders in those metropolis that are
trying to help catalyze the awakening
are being displaced because they
themselves don't get paid three or five
thousand dollars a month to pay for
these egregious rents so there's
actually there's actually a a serious
economic point to conspicuous
consumption that directly impacts
spiritual awakening and that I'm still
trying to figure out how to disseminate
memes around in stories that then awaken
people to figuring out how we can maybe
go back to some things like a Lorenzo de
Medici which patron Michelangelo da
Vinci buona celli into the Italian
Renaissance so that seems like a very
interesting thing but it also just going
back to the most first principle which
is an immediate return hunter-gathering
style life doesn't even have excessive
wealth creation that creates these voids
in people's spirits where they need to
fill it with addiction to conspicuous
consumption and stuff like
so you even mentioned that point about
what we talked about with Chris Ryan on
the show and what we've talked about in
the program we talked for sailing about
and we're talking about now just there's
this this this this most optimal way to
progress and most optimal way to evolve
and just that being this grand challenge
that creation or source is channeling
through us as we play the symphony as
how will we figure out how to evolve and
we haven't really you know I think the
the the challenge is to identify what
are the parameters that help in that
yeah you know because whenever people
say they want to limit something it's
seen as okay that's taking away freedom
or that's taking away this so awaken
don't even need to see it because awaken
people don't by 12th boats and cars and
planes and stuff like that so it's not
even taking away of freedom it's more
like you awaken to reality oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah but I think that that's
that's the resistance because that's
that's our habit that's what's it what's
true yeah that's what's ingrained right
yeah and we we need to find a way to say
well here are six parameters that are
actually gonna be helpful for everybody
to be a bit more healthy and a bit more
balanced and a bit more whatever you
know support it in their creativity and
have a bit more time to whatever
meditate preysing yeah do whatever they
they want to do because right now so
much of that when you look at where it's
happening its privileged people who go
right because they have the money to go
right or those completely out of the
economic machinery that or or the oral
that's the other possibility yeah yeah
so I think there's a lot of collective
learning that we need to do and we are
currently lacking the wise leaders who
actually are able or seeing it and are
able to formulate it let's talk about
these parameters because I have a
proposal that I want to see if more
people will want to get behind which is
why don't we take the if you look at a
hierarchy of wealth around the planet
there's 1500 billionaires around the
planet there's all these leaders of
countries there's the companies leaders
of different companies major companies
then there's like a spiritual hierarchy
where it's people at the top are the
most enlightened why don't we figure out
a way to map the biometrics of states of
interconnectedness and then try and see
how truly enlightened awakened these
billionaires and leaders of countries
and corporations are and that's a
top-down thing but then there's also
like a bottom-up thing which is getting
more people to want to play and
harmonize on music and art and all these
other types of things but that's not
funded by the economic machinery so
people can't live while they do that so
I like that I like the proposal in just
just blatantly honestly just calling
people out like no you have literal
psychopathic tendencies it's viewed in
all these different ways let's take a
biometrics data scan of your body and
see if we're right or if you are truly
all loved like you claim to be because I
think Dalai Lama versus Jeff Bezos will
have completely different biometric
signatures period well I hope you're
right and I think you know confrontation
is good and is necessary loving loving
yeah yeah well actually you know when
you confront
one it means you care for the person if
you don't care for the person you don't
confront them right confrontation means
you're already engaged right because
you're saying I want to talk to you
because you're wrong right but I want to
talk to you right at theirs there is
that and I think that's that's really
important you know and we're not doing
very well with that level of
disagreement and actually talking about
it I think we haven't figured out you
see it I mean that there two more things
that we haven't figured out you know
what one is
you know utopian thinking is inherently
is dangerous right because we could
probably come up with in five minutes on
certain things where we all say that
that would be a good utopian thing right
but then what does it take to implement
that right and that's where things go
wrong right and because well if the
three of us think it's the right idea
then we creating a dictatorship
basically and that doesn't you know that
just never works you know so that's
where many initially good ideas have
gone wrong you know but the the I was
gonna say oh the other thing is the
second thing is really we're dealing
with a scale that I'm not sure that we
have yet developed the capacity to
actually deal with it because when you
think about it everything we have said
about balancing and indigenous people
well those are all relatively
small-scale societies right which means
basically you know which I thought was
very interesting when I went to my first
workshops with Carl Rogers right they
were about between 120 and 160 people
there right well you don't get to know
120 or 160 people but you get familiar
with their faces you walk around there's
a certain comfort and you know who is
part of the community
not right do you get to that level of
comfort now we are trying to deal with
problems with millions of people 300
million people in this country and
whatever it is right and I think we have
yet to develop the capacities of how to
to implement any of these and I think
what we need to learn is there are
certain things that maybe need maybe
need to be done centrally and there are
other things that need to be done very
locally and we don't know which is which
we haven't sort of come to that and I
think that's probably a science in its
own right yeah you know how the balance
between a Dunbar number of 150 versus a
country size of 300 million versus the
collective size of 8 billion and
figuring out what needs to be
implemented at a community level of 150
versus on a 8 billion person level and
how to actually do that yeah the skills
problem yeah yeah and I think it has not
received enough research and I mean
attention on all on all levels
yeah well one problem is the huge volume
concern for a number of years there have
been model communities both in Europe
and the United States plant communities
like the one in Columbia Maryland the
architectural complexes where everybody
lives in a huge house which each had at
their own section which are being built
now in some parts of West Germany the
people in the Hong Kong but mastered
this ages ago
they have many apartments mi and I in a
huge building everybody has very little
space everybody gets along fairly well
together this is of course before the
curve unrest but that has nothing to do
with these little mini villages that
they have these huge apartment houses
so there's ways in which community has
evolved almost to the point of Vermont
you might say there's a collective
consciousness and collective
consciousness is easy to spot on animals
like swarms of ants for example in
Africa the antelope running by the
thousands even while beasts running in
tandem and I've seen this in Bali with
human beings were a group of probably
two or three hundred people get together
and they chant is one organism and it's
a beautiful thing to watch and people
are absolutely in central each other
and this is not done rashly this is
where consciousness alteration comes in
and they look at this as something this
a source of worship because by attaining
the oneness with themselves they attain
oneness with their deities and with the
universe so the masses of humans do come
up from time to time and I think more
often than not it's an amicable group
that's that one thing fall out of place
and you're in the risk of everything
come Belene come tumbling down
so that actually kind of got us onto the
collective consciousness route a little
bit
let's also kind of yours there's
basically lots of places within nature
that we can take how trees redistribute
access resources how the certain swarm
like evolutionary behaviors operate how
our symphony as humans is also being
played out and how there's ways to
redesign the social fabric and social
contract for maximizing prosperity for
all
on a cosmic consciousness of planetary
consciousness level actually think you
said before we started that you had some
ways that you wanted to be a devil's
advocate to this this world I think you
know when we talk about collective
consciousness and cosmic consciousness
you know I mean there's there's a you
know very important things and these
experiences of of unity that happen when
you know people two or three hundred
people chant together you know I mean
that is blissful that's amazing that
that's wonderful and I think I mean I
see anything that is a cosmic awareness
or planetary awareness really as complex
so as something that includes these
blissful states but also that includes
awareness of our humanity where there is
pain where there are things that have
gone wrong where there are people that
are suffering and I at times do this as
sort of a meditative exercise I tried to
to be aware of all the different
suffering that is in the world and it's
actually really really hard and yes it's
really hard yes and because there is so
much unnecessary suffering right I mean
why do kids die so many millions of kids
die
you know why are there so many people
were unnecessarily sick when there's the
simplest cheapest ways of treating them
right etc etc so but I think that it
needs to be part of the capacity of of
holding that you know because we so
often I mean this is I guess my devil's
advocate statement we try to run towards
the bliss and there's nothing wrong with
bliss but I think the bliss becomes a
richer
and deeper if we also confront the
shadow whether it's our own personal
shadow or whether it's our cultural
shadows you know whether it's the slave
trade whether it's a Native American
genocide or as a German whether it's the
the show or the Holocaust you know or
whatever it is depending on where you're
and I think or you know right now you
know the incredible inequality economic
inequality were the shadow of what's
happening at the Mexican border right
yeah so if if that is not a part of that
planetary cosmic awareness I think you
know I would call it ungrounded but I
think that is a really important
spiritual practice an ethical practice
that to be aware of that and so often
these are situations where we feel
helpless right I mean I feel helpless
about what's happening at the Mexican
border you know what's happening to the
kids right or what have what's happening
in terms of the increasing inequality
that doesn't seem to stop it's
interesting how collective consciousness
can be used in different purposes also
you see a church choir that certainly is
collective consciousness a group of
monks chanting on the other side of the
world
that's collective consciousness and
these numbers might go into the hundreds
and then you see mass warfare and you
see armies storming a fort as and that
also looks like this that's a looks like
collective consciousness to me yes
so even though we are thinking in terms
of the individual now that has become
more and more prominent for the right of
rise of Western culture we consist the
collective consciousness all over it all
over the place you you said something I
was so interested just that we if we try
and go towards that that bliss without
going through the process of actual
healing the deepest traumas we could
actually experience more bliss more play
more love by doing the hard work I'm a
huge proponent of doing that and that
again just requires these shifts you see
I think we've set up a polarity we're
sort of critical thinking and bless are
like they don't go together and I think
what we need to do is you know we need
to whatever drink ayahuasca and have
critical thinking right and and we are
not practicing that right because we
just want to go into the the Bliss of
that experience and yeah that's good
right
but it can't be to the detriment of the
other side you know and you know what
one of the things stand that I've always
appreciated about you is that you go
into these far out places and allow
yourself to just be present in in a
totally non-judgmental way but it
doesn't stop you from critical thinking
about them right and I think that
capacity is so important and it's it's
not an either/or right and that's what
we need to teach in schools right that's
what we need to teach in universities
yes look at the most fundamental first
principles of pedagogy and you find that
currently emotional social spiritual
intelligence in this in this current
system and especially like the West and
even in in China with going towards this
gal cow stood the same style in essence
that remove spiritual intelligence
remove emotional and social intelligence
--is and and that's why we have that
huge imbalance
so when you do teach from a first
principle to children that are being
born into the world that your breaths of
air are coming from phytoplankton and
trees that your bite from the apples
coming from the power of the Sun that
these interconnected principles are most
first principle and it doesn't live
exclusively from rationality and
critical thinking but they harmonize I
think our task is to harmonize them and
to integrate them amen don't purpose of
this program has most recently been to
harmonize balance these two said looking
around and seeing hundreds of identical
penguins but I've still got to be me we
have sharing with eight billion other
humans but also ten million other
species and there's a unique instrument
or puzzle piece in the big symphony
that's being created and to know that we
are all one but that we have our unique
instrument to play in the oneness yeah
that's another big thing that we've been
talking about in the program a lot again
this is another thing that seems like a
paradox clothes expense that clothes in
special really is but from the top it
looks like a complete unity and then you
have the outliers with the exceptions
well that's the exception that proves
the rule though I think that's the
exception that's a part of the rule you
have to have the old Flyers Wow I feel
really good really good think so are
there other points that we want to I
think we really covered a lot of ground
that happen very well yes I think so too
I'm so grateful I want to thank you both
Wow
thank you you're gonna thank you Siri
thank you I just hope it gets you a lot
of the listeners and viewers I hope that
you guys catalyze the awakening that we
hope to all do even these small little
butterfly effects that go out I admire
the way you have your little studio
shows up here amazing it's so powerful
it's so mobily this is one of the things
about technology and the democratization
of it you no longer need multi-million
dollar studios from couple decades ago
you can just take a couple tens of
thousands dollars of equipment and just
make something happen yeah and it's so
cool and hopefully can light up more
young people to be creative so thank you
for all your beautiful work and all the
people that you get on the show I mean
there are some amazing conversations
always free never pay Walt always
creative commons people can repurpose
this content as they please they can
there's never pay walls on this stuff so
there's some main principles to our
ethos that we follow and we also highly
recommend everyone to check out the
links in the bio to both Stanley and
uragan x' work and their profiles and
their books those links are in the bio
below as well all these concepts that
we've been talking about on the program
they all they both right
about in-depth so check out those links
in the bio below and support them
support the other artists entrepreneurs
and spiritual leaders in your
communities and around the world help
them flourish you can support us we
heard the good word support us all those
links are below so you can tune in doing
cool things like having these great
conversations and scaling our content
I'm really looking forward to these next
couple of decades in the unfolding of
the symphony thank you both so much
thank you everyone for tuning in much
love manifest your dreams into the world
see you soon